welcome to this video playing kumara
9898 no info maybe sweetie just fifteen
or sixteen years old okay
the names are I guess yeah mmm
interesting that's a career continuation
b6 e in this concrete position what if I
go you for maybe I can do that he takes
on d5 I have to serve ideas like a
bishop you fall okay mmm yeah this is a
very tricky way to set up your pieces as
black and some the bishop on b7 might be
really misplaced yeah for sure
but still you have 94 castles I mean
this is a very risky business taking the
point okay remember risky businesses I
think to hit two nicely put not quite
sure what he's playing now I have 93 f5
this is a main point and also sometimes
Knight b5 is a very problematic news
it's even possible right now but okay
this is this quick Knight to f5 is
dangerous on its own
Wow not even some seconds there maybe
Ruki one was such a strong threat
possible okay Bishop g5 or yeah this is
this is this is probably simple and good
yeah non-threatening 94 so I think he
absolutely must take on c3 okay it does
not seem to be the case okay I can I can
already sacrifice but I can also just
keep the pin just keeping the pin should
be a good okay so what now trying to
just further improve okay one maybe and
this should be six but okay need to get
more pieces into the tech I don't think
I have a direct win somewhere
Bishop's III 23 maybe this also
threatens Bishop f6 just
Jack not so sure how much this is
threatening really
if I just take here play Queen f3 hmm or
queen a3 immediately is a strong run
Bishop a5 Queen f5 is very strong and
night h6 is a big threat
okay if I take aged six now is there
some some sort of defense or not I don't
see it ready or was there some better
move my reticence must be must be enough
ready what is what is this responds him
okay this quite a number of moves now at
four as well Queen Anne for Bishop f6
it's not enough I think Queen f5 is also
not exactly bad but not wrongly not not
winning
it's funny that if he moves the Queen
for example to be eight I have Queen f6
that's a quite quite nice meeting it's
actually happening it's a quite nice
meeting the meeting idea takes bishop
takes a secured checkmate just with
minor pieces
okay mm how do is there some some some
nice way to to win this like a knight f5
or something takes bishop takes and this
is probably no medium okay just take
here check yeah just take him hmm Bishop
takes Queen takes I want all this one
here can also be check can also be done
and now King h8 there's some Queen g6
yeah don't stay don't see a quicker
cooker 1/3 h7 made black resigns young
as if this was really a super dangerous
position hey I don't really know I mean
somewhere around here you should
probably start to think of it trying to
defend this but I think it gets to two
indefensible proportions right here
after this I don't think I can pluck him
keep this together somehow
okay one supposed to be even better but
okay yeah well the computer is normally
even more ruthless than a and then a
human it gives the rookie one with +3
and this is what I played 96 and rookie
3 here with the rook clip yeah this was
my original idea but then I spotted the
Bishop c2 Queen d3 idea but this is also
also +3 or something and also
it's too much he and night HGS was
already a win with Ruby III coming and
Ruby III okay yeah it's it's really a
bit much
it just seems to win as well now taking
on g7 was winning this as well though
it's it's just too much
Queen age three year was so strong okay
yeah I didn't I didn't really see I can
go here and win okay okay I never bought
I've never really watched it up Queen f6
was nice
and here Queen f5 is a quicker Shepherd
okay just just one point per game
okay thanks for watching